I'm a firefighter speaking of which I'm
a fighter
firefighter in Australia and in the time
I've been in this job I've been several
jobs that were very challenging I've
entered burning homes to extinguish
fires and search for residents and their
pets I search for victims during times
of flood and help people evacuate their
homes in times of natural disasters I've
attended car crashes and cut victims
from vehicles and pulled deceased people
from others I've I also know that I'm
not alone I am aware of the fact that
while I've been doing this countless
firefighters were on the globe or
thousands of times braver than me and
I've done things that the vast majority
of the population would not be capable
of and that doesn't even acknowledge the
courage of our police and paramedics and
our military who step up day after day
to do what has to be done because of if
not me then whom my question is this how
do you suggest those in the front line
deal with the trivial issues at home I
attended a very severe car accident a
head-on collision with a school bus full
of children and another car thankful
thankfully all the children in the
school bus were ok but it took us three
hours to cut the driver from the car and
she had very serious injuries and was
airlifted to a hospital when I got home
that night I was confronted by an upset
girlfriend who wanted to talk about some
extra extraordinarily trivial issue
which I struggled to listen to the whole
time she was talking I just kept
thinking about the job and making sure
I'd done everything I possibly could
have for the driver but I was also aware
of the fact that my fiance's problems
are important to her so I need to be
supportive I listen for as long as I
could listen for as long as I could then
unfortunately I just said your day could
have been a lot worse no one spent three
hours cutting you out of a car so be
thankful I know I can't be alone on this
I know police paramedics in the military
would be suffering the same thing how do
you suggest is the best way to deal with
this check
so it was always always my goal to
protect my family from darkness and evil
in the world that includes these kind of
things you want to shield them from this
now this doesn't mean to keep them
oblivious you don't want them thinking
that the world that you've created for
them that's well protected and secure
you don't want them thinking that that's
the way the whole world is you don't
want them thinking that but I sure
didn't throw this kind of stuff at my
family on a regular basis but I took
pride and I think that that's the answer
here take pride in letting your family
or your loved ones live in worlds where
they're trivial issues are the most
important thing in their world the most
impactful thing in the world for them
okay so that's that's number one
and if you get yourself a little bit of
satisfaction every time your your
significant other complains that you
know the the ice machine isn't really
working up to full speed it's really
horrible mm-hmm
right you should be you should be proud
think yourself yeah well you know what
let me let me take a look at it maybe
there's a kink in the water line I don't
know but we'll try and get that thing up
to speed so you can have cold drinks cuz
that's where I want your world to be
right I want you to have plenty of ice
so for your drinks or whatever so that's
that's it if you can if you can put your
your family in that kind of a protected
environment you should be proud of it
and you should be and the way they
indicate that to you they don't say hey
thank you for letting me live in a
protected environment they don't say
that to you
there in the environment they don't even
know that they're in it the way they the
way they let you know that they're in
that environment is when they when they
complain about trivial things so that's
number one
the other thing is try and try and see
things from other people's perspective
you know in in this case my my wife's
right so my wife would say things is a
big deal to her and for her it was a big
deal and like I just said I wanted it to
be a big deal for her and also I'll tell
you what we're talking about
firefighters and military and police but
this goes to other non uniformed jobs as
well if if you can leave your work at
work because you think some you know
every job
there's stresses at every job and you're
out there grinding and you're in trouble
with the boss or you're trying to get a
project fig figured out you've got all
the stress coming down on you or you've
lost money or you've got a huge deal on
the table or whatever the case may be if
you can isolate your family from that as
much as you can and I'm not saying into
an unhealthy level where you're just not
telling them what's going on but bear
the burden man bear the burden of that
you that you hold to protect your family
so yeah that's what I think that's what
I think we we do our best to protect our
family and our loved ones from the
darkness the pressure the stress the
evil in the world again you don't make
them oblivious you don't disconnect from
them in order to do that but you shield
them from it and you bear the burden
yourself so that they don't have to bear
it as much again you don't want your
kids growing up to be spoiled you don't
want your wife to be saying if I don't
get of a latte this morning I will
absolutely not even right you don't want
to be married to that person yeah not
even I did that pretty good didn't I my
middle daughter is like the funniest
person ever and she can do all these
crazy nice tea I'm stealing her material
right there because she'll do that Jason
she'll say that is so oh my god it's not
even you know she's kidding because she
knows that there's human beings like
that in the world that say not even
there's nothing at the end of it
yeah that's us I think that might be
something new no that's not evil you
know I've heard
I can't even though I can't even oh it's
the same thing the same thing yes I'm
updated yeah new it's just a different
angle on it but yeah hey thanks for uh
thanks for doing all that hard work man
that's that's awesome I know I see
firefighters police officers military
people all the time I hear them all the
time and yeah try and shield your family
as much as you can don't drag them down
look down into the darkness with you
yeah it seems like a good and take pride
in it that's what I was gonna say it's
like take pride in its like embracing
the role as like the captain kind of
yeah you know where it's like yeah you
know the wife's mad about you know they
put cream in our coffee and she asked
for a nonfat milk that's from Seinfeld
bitter um and you know whatever and
she's pissed and meanwhile you know you
just pulled a lady out for three hours
by the way bus and car crash head-on
collision so as he you know you embrace
the role it's like okay you know boom
I'm dealing oh one second I'm dealing
with straight-up life and death and kids
and accidents and tragedy and then one
second later I'm dealing with
essentially nothing right but it's my
wife's feelings that's what I'm dealing
with
my wife's feeling I'm not dealing with
nonfat milk versus cream I'm not dealing
with that I'm dealing with my wife's
feelings and that's part of the job too
so you can't just be like hey I'm gonna
do my job one second I'm gonna do my job
really good in the next second I'm not
gonna do it so good you can't do that
embrace the role that's the guy who gets
the job done regardless how big how
small so so as a husband this is where I
can speak from cuz I've been a husband
for eight years successfully cuz I'm
currently husband too so there be you
know how like people have anyway but so
you know how you know people they'll
tell you something and then you'll be
like wait what do you mean by that
you're kind of offended like are you
like are you kind of digging at me or
something like that you know like that
kind stuff even though you know kinda
they were right like that was a little
passive-aggressive little comment kind
of thing so every once in a while when
I'd experienced that not
that happens all the time but if it ever
happened what I do to kind of combat
that anger cuz brah okay I'm the kind
where like if there's like a you saying
passive-aggressive from your wife yes
and what you do to combat the anger
would be it would be trying to move this
story racing no it's relevant to this
Thun important I think it helps it
totally helps where I embrace the role
of the dude I don't know for lack of
better than the captain you know embrace
the role a captain where sure she's
passive-aggressive whatever you know
maybe I'll overtime I'll start to
understand more or whatever but so I
like envision myself as Superman for and
her passive-aggressive comments or
bullets and they're just bouncing off of
me just like bullets off Superman yeah
that's cool that's cool until the fact
that if you don't react and she's gonna
escalate she wants some kind of reaction
out of you yeah so sometimes you have to
give them some kind of reaction yeah
otherwise they'll continue to escalate
to a point where you do react yes yeah
so I read that little or a while ago
yeah yeah no reaction is not always good
right so and I don't you gotta say you
gotta say the bullet hits you and you
gotta say oh that bullet hurt oh yeah I
should be a little more careful yeah
bullets are flying around that's how I
need to be a little bit more
you know careful of these bullets they
can really hurt me right be careful but
see how your your tone and stuff is like
there's no anger there yeah yeah but so
that's what I mean I mean it's just to
combat the anger not the problem-solving
think that's a whole nother thing as far
as I'm concerned like if she's
passive-aggressive or mad about I don't
know it's cuz I put the dish away when
it was wet and dry dator wet that skill
was by the way but I'm just saying if
it's just that's a whole different thing
so if I anger why's the bullets bounce
off of me boom I don't get angry then I
can start addressing those issues the
ones that you're talking about but I
mean to combat the straight-up anger
yeah keep your emotions in check yeah -
like her insults are bouncing off of me
like Superman it help sometimes